i want to bring in dr mark siegel for
analysis as to what we heard in about
the first
hour and a half or so of that hearing
doctor thank you for joining us
hi blake good to be back back with you
yeah i want to
walk you through a couple headlines at
least as as i saw it dr anthony fauci
saying that he is quote
cautiously optimistic that there will be
a vaccine either
by the end of this year or at the
beginning of next year and whenever
there might be a vaccine
he says in 2021 there was a quote
reasonable period of time that whoever
wants to get that vaccine
would be able to take it at that point
fauci and the cdc director
doctor also saying that they believe it
is imperative
that k to 12 schools or grades resume
in person this upcoming school year what
did you make of what we've heard so far
so both of those points are really
really important dr fauci on the vaccine
made an extremely important point that's
never been made publicly before he
compared it to the hiv vaccine and he
said
with coronavirus we're seeing the
antibodies we're seeing the
the what you need the neutralizing
antibodies that's the reason for his
optimism
there's a strong immune response already
when you're getting over this virus
and you you could almost feel his
excitement about these virus
about these vaccine candidates so that
that was
very very impressive he's also said to
me by the way about
schools reopening and the word he used
is one i've used too which is the
default
should be that schools reopen there's
too much public health damage
by not considering that and dr fauci
acknowledged that today
that there's absolutely a huge public
health cost
for keeping the schools closed and dr
redfield said that
as well there was a very they both
didn't but i'm just what i wanted
yeah no i i want to jump on that for a
second because they talked about
k through 12 schools grades which is
obviously important
but i can say this selfishly as well
that there's a lot of parents in this
country
millions of them with two three and
four-year-olds as well
pre-k and below what do you do with
those children
well blake that's even more of a problem
because again
there's so much care that's needed at
home and there's care with
with going to daycare facilities and we
don't believe that very young children
uh are spreading the virus as much as
older children
and or that they get very sick from it